purificación Gallardo es uno de los
rostros de la lucha por la memoria de
las víctimas de la represión franquista
todos los días visita a sus padres que
tienen más de 90 años
mampa qué tal estáis en este apartamento
de los suburbios de Madrid decorado con
recuerdos familiares hay un vacío tenía
el abuelo Felipe tenía 12 años cuando el
régimen franquista encarceló a su padre
y lo ejecutó actualmente como él
114.000 desaparecidos de la dictadura
aún no han sido exhumados
tu padre
una pena No yo sabía que mi padre era un
hombre que era una inteligencia era un
poco difícil
tenemos que intentar recuperar lo
primero sus cuerpos y recuperar que se
haga que se conozca la verdad
es justicia y reparación la reparación
ya es un poco tarde porque realmente
pero la justicia Sí es muy importante yo
pienso
purificación busco y localizó los restos
de su abuelo por su cuenta pero los
bloqueos políticos han impedido su
exhumación hasta ahora
me dijeron la concejala que está mi
abuelo en el departamento 4 que es justo
aquí pero cuando
mencioné la palabra exhumar y llevarle
de badajoz a su pueblo valdetorres donde
está mi abuela
ahí ya cambió todo
la nueva ley de memoria democrática da
Esperanza a las familias que antes
estaban abandonadas a su suerte
por primera vez el estado se encarga de
la búsqueda e identificación de los
miles de desaparecidos
en Valladolid entre los miles de tumbas
del cementerio del Carmen se encuentra
una de las mayores fosas comunes jamás
encontradas
buenos días
cómo va eso Angélica
Julio es miembro de una asociación para
la memoria Él es quien lidera los
trabajos con su equipo anex sumado los
restos de
250 víctimas del franquismo
son personas que están colocadas están
alineadas uno junto al otro lo cual no
se está confirmando que son
enterramientos procedentes de los
juicios sumarios que se celebraron en
ese momento el gobierno español destinó
60.000 euros para estas excavaciones en
el pasado Julio solía recurrir a
voluntarios por falta de fondos este
financiamiento le ha permitido contratar
a profesionales como Angélica han estado
mucho tiempo enterrados solo se
acordaban de ellos sus familiares y
bueno los sacas a la luz y por lo menos
se da a conocer a la gente un caso tan
reciente como ha sido este
Pedro Sánchez visitó las excavaciones en
octubre primera vez que un jefe de
gobierno en funciones hace algo así una
señal fuerte Aunque tardía para las
asociaciones de familiares de las
víctimas
agradecidos no que se hayan fijado
Precisamente en el trabajo que desde
hace 20 años Está realizando la rmh de
Valladolid
aprobada en el senado con 128 votos a
favor y 113 en contra la nueva ley de
memoria democrática es divisoria 47 años
después de la muerte de Franco los
políticos de la derecha consideran que
revive las heridas del pasado España
nunca ha juzgado a los responsables de
la dictadura la reconciliación nacional
se basó en una ley de amnistía
Rafael Arias Salgado fue uno de sus
impulsores
y en esta foto con el rey Juan Carlos
es muy poco tiempo después de la ley de
amnistía este proyecto de ley trata de
deslegitimar el proceso de transición
democrática y considerar que todo este
periodo es una democracia insuficiente e
imperfecta dirigida y controlada por no
demócratas la ley tampoco convence a
muchas asociaciones de víctimas Emilio
es nieto de un activista republicano
ejecutado frente al arco de la Victoria
monumento elegido a la gloria del
franquismo no oculta su escepticismo
existe una ley desde el año 2007 en
España que dice que este arco es ilegal
han pasado 15 años y ningún gobierno ha
aplicado esa ley ahora tenemos otra ley
no tengo por qué pensar que van a
cambiar las cosas la ley de memoria
democrática prevé la creación de una
comisión de investigación que estudiará
las violaciones de los Derechos Humanos
cometidas hasta principios de los años
80 Esto no es suficiente para acabar con
la impunidad según Emilio la ley que se
ha aprobado no va a juzgar a nadie no
nos va a contar Quiénes eran los
verdugos de la dictadura porque quiere
hacer un censo de víctimas pero no
quiere hacer un censo de verdugos y no
va a reparar las víctimas no las va a
indemnizar Entonces
qué justicia es esa
la ley de memoria democrática sigue
siendo frágil la derecha española ya ha
anunciado que de llegar al poder el
próximo año la derogará